um this song is it's a song about how
underfoot is when you can have friends
who you can trust and who can light on
and depend on and so the reason why our
SETI is because I don't know if you
remember but on the first day that I had
you as a class right
I gave you a head had like eight points
on it and I had my turntable in the back
and I made a pump not a six point plan
Snape explains my eyes okay the plan I
think my times are election so the
promise I made you and it was a promise
on my part and a request from you is I
promised you I would work hard for you
and the request I made of you is that
you've worked and I wasn't asking
something of you that I wasn't gonna do
myself do you remember that yeah so the
reason why I asked you here is that even
though I've never taught you before six
years no but um I feel like even though
I never said those words to you and
maybe made a promise and expecting you
to promise back to me you just did it
anyway
and so even though you'll get to
probably watch it later I want you to be
in the broom so yes so that's why I
picked this song and also because I
visit a couple other reasons it's
actually a very mathematical song as
you'll see shortly and this is the final
Queen quit job I didn't realize this
until for awhile I started practicing it
and I was like ah this song even has my
name like if you listen my name gets my
name gets it off to the course you hear
anyway so um you'll have to forgive me
because it's a really hard song term
it's a really easy song to play but it's
a very hard song to sing because the
singer he just has this crazy voice so
um yeah I'll do my best okay but yeah
let's see if I can even remember the
lyrics anyway
stop if you ever find yourself stuck off
the sea
Sam
I drew
lost in the top you can't see
gosh
you can't
if you what's next if you toss and turn
beside
you can
no you can
I am hurt over these last two years
some of you was in for so good six that
I bet someone you could count on who if
you wanted to ask something
any time I was there I hope I've been
that for as many of you as I can and now
I'm gonna hand it over to you and I know
I can count on you guys to do proud and
to do really well and meet people who
yeah I just can't wait to see what you
guys go in life I was sad to see you go
but yeah you're gonna achieve some
really amazing things in I can't wait to
see